Argentina es ese país famoso por tener
ese acento que crees que puedes imitar
pero que en realidad no puedes. El año
pasado los argentinos cambiaron de
presidente tras doce años de dominio
del matrimonio Kirchner,  Mauricio
Macri es el nuevo hombre llamado a dar
un giro de 180 grados a este país. Sólo
lleva nueve meses en el poder y en este
tiempo los argentinos ya han sufrido
su primer apagón eléctrico
-el primero en décadas-, ha subido la luz,
ha subido el desempleo; la inflación
está en un 40% y las popularidad
de Macri está cayendo en picado mientras
Buenos Aires se llena de protestas. Pero
esperad un momento, ¿de verdad un hombre
que no lleva ni un año en el poder es
capaz de destruir el país tan
rápidamente? Para entender lo que está
ocurriendo en Argentina,
necesitamos un poquito de contexto
histórico. De entrada tenemos que saber
que Argentina es el décimo país en
recursos naturales del mundo: tienen
petróleo gas minerales y agricultura
como para poder alimentar al 60% de la
humanidad.
A principios del siglo XX Argentina era
el quinto país más rico del mundo, muy
por encima de Austria y muy cerquita de
Estados Unidos.
De hecho, cuando los almacenes Harrods
quisieron abrir su primera tienda fuera
del Reino Unido no eligieron Nueva York
sino Buenos Aires.
Sin embargo, en 1930 el ejército da el
primer golpe de estado en Argentina.
Durante estos tiempos la economía
mundial no estaba en su mejor momento
era la época del crack del 29 y eso
juntado con la represión de la
dictadura hizo que  Argentina sufriera
más que ningún otro país.
Años después se restaura la democracia
y llega al poner un señor que se llama
Juan Domingo Perón.
Lo cierto es que Perón tampoco fue
capaz de restaurar la economía
argentina
sin embargo su carisma y su influencia
llega hasta nuestros días.
Es más podemos hablar de toda una
ideología llamada peronismo que es una
mezcla entre nacionalismo extremo,
mercados cerrados, economía muy
intervenida y todo aderezado con la
salsa picante del populismo. A partir de
aquí la historia de argentina se puede
resumir en un tira y afloja entre golpes
de estado militares y políticos
peronistas que le suceden. En los años
50 el ejército vuelve a dar otro golpe
de estado, pero Perón logra mantenerse
en el poder; después otro golpe de
estado,
luego perón otra vez; años más tarde
otro golpe de estado,
después gobierno peronista; luego golpe
de estado y peronistas; golpe de estado y
peronistas.
Así podemos contar hasta seis golpes de
estado con gobiernos peronistas entre
medias. ¿El resultado? Que a principios del
siglo XXI
el que fuera el quinto país más rico
del planeta tenía ahora mismo la
economía por los suelos.
Estamos ya en el año 2003 y es en ese momento
cuando entra en la Casa Rosada el
matrimonio más glamouroso de toda la
política internacional
los Kirchner, que por supuesto son de
ideología peronista. Y sí, digo
matrimonio porque primero estuvo el
marido Néstor y después, en 2007, le
sucedió su mujer Cristina. Las mismas
ideas, la misma familia.
Vamos que todo quedó en casa.
Vamos a centrarnos en la época de Cristina
porque fue la última presidenta antes
de Macri y porque estuvo mucho más
tiempo que su marido. Una de sus medidas
clave fue el impago de la deuda que
tenía Argentina con los inversores
internacionales.
"Amenazan y hostigan con
acciones sobre la economía de nuestro
país"
Así es como se desató una guerra entre
el gobierno de kirchner y los inversores,
principalmente éste que vemos aquí que
se llama Paul Singer y que luchó hasta
el final para que le devolvieran lo que
le debían.
"En ausencia de
un acuerdo con los acreedores gente a la
que se le debe mucho dinero
el acceso a los capitales
internacionales está truncado están
pagando muchos más intereses extra es
literalmente miles de millones de
dólares al año"
El tema de la deuda externa de
los países es muy complejo y nos va a
dar para otro video pero lo cierto es
que con batallas o sin batallas
si tú no le pagas lo que le debes a
los acreedores es muy difícil que
encuentres nuevas personas dispuestas
a prestarte dinero, y esto es lo que
le pasó a Argentina. De repente Cristina se
encontró con que no podía buscar
financiación en los mercados
internacionales.
Sin embargo su programa político se
basaba precisamente en aumentar el gasto
público.
"Desocupados, no registrados,
registrados con ingresos altos con
ingresos bajos,
todos están subsidiados en transporte,
en luz, en gas, en agua y en combustible"
Entonces, ¿de dónde puedes sacar dinero
para poder financiar todos estos
subsidios? Pues subiendo los impuestos al
sector económico más potente del
país que en este caso era el del
cultivo de soja.
Así que en 2008 Cristina puso un
tributo de 35% a la
exportación de soja.
Esto generó muchísimas protestas y
hasta una huelga en el sector que se
prolongó por seis días.
En otras palabras Kirchner estaba ahogando
su principal sector económico,
por eso en poco tiempo Cristina se dio
cuenta de que no recaudaba lo suficiente
como para financiar su gasto público. ¿Y
cuál es la tentación de todos los
políticos cuando no tienen dinero? Los
que estáis suscritos a VisualPolitik
lo sabéis muy bien: imprimir billetes. Sin
embargo, Cristina no quería subir la
inflación
así que junto a esta expansión
monetaria sacó una medida a la que
llamó el cepo cambiario. Es decir, que el cambio de peso
argentino a dólar americano estaría
fijado por ley y os preguntaréis, ¿qué
pasa cuando un político fija un tipo de
cambio concreto en lugar de utilizar el
que fija el mercado? Pues que aunque el
gobierno te diga que un dólar vale ocho
pesos argentinos,
lo cierto es que nadie te los va a
vender a ese precio y así es cómo
surgieron dos tipos de cambio paralelos
que los que véis este vídeo desde
Argentina seguramente ya conoceréis
por un lado estaba el dólar oficial y por
el otro el llamado dólar blue que era
el fijado a precio de mercado.
De repente las calles de Buenos Aires se
llenaron de unos señores a los que
llamaban arbolitos que se dedicaban a
venderte dólar bñue por supuesto de forma
ilegal.
"¿Usted lo que se llama normalmente un arbolito?"
"Yo no, pero sí se les llaman
arbolitos"
Y entonces, ¿quién era capaz de
vender dólares al tipo de cambio
oficial? Pues solamente una institución
que era el Banco Central de Argentina.
Casi todos los bancos centrales tienen
una reserva de divisas extranjeras así
que en este caso se dedicaban a vender
los dólares que ya tenían guardados. En
estos tres años se perdieron 20.252
millones de dólares de las reservas del
Banco Central. El dólar oficial asalto
de 4,26 pesos a 8,50 y el blue
protagonista de estos tres años saltó
de 4,49 a 15 pesos"
Y por eso,
la inflación oficial en Argentina no
era tan alta pero lógicamente estas
encuestas no reflejaban la vida real de
los ciudadanos y por supuesto no se
tenían en cuenta en el extranjero.
Medios como The Economist rechazaron
utilizar estas estadísticas que
proporcionaba el gobierno argentino por
este empeño de Kirchner en ocultar
el mercado paralelo. Lo primero que hace Macri
al día siguiente de llegar a la Casa
Rosada es quitar el cepo cambiario. Ese
mismo día el cambio oficial del dólar
se multiplica por dos, por supuesto para los
que estaban utilizando el dólar blue no
supuso ninguna diferencia pero para los
que sí que eran capaces de comprar
dólares al tipo oficial tuvo unos
efectos catastróficos. En general todos
aquellos negocios que tenían acceso al
Banco Central de Argentina se vieron
afectados y por eso no es que este año
haya crecido a la inflación en
Argentina es que había estado siempre
ahí, sólo que camuflada.
Lo mismo ocurrió con la energía como
hemos visto antes
el gobierno de kirchner subvencionaba la
electricidad que a los argentinos les
costaba más o menos lo mismo que
tomarse un café. Para pagar estos
subsidios
Argentina llegó a utilizar más del 16% del presupuesto público. Para
que os hagáis una idea el pago de las
pensiones en un estado normal no llega
al 40% del presupuesto y en este caso
solamente estamos hablando de 16 para
una subvención muy concreta.
Lógicamente cuando Macri quita el subsidio
se producen protestas en la calle y
hasta un apagón eléctrico.
Todo esto explica la caída de Macri en
los índices de popularidad que ha
pasado en menos de nueve meses de un 66
por ciento a un 44%.
Sin embargo los partidarios de Macri
aseguran que este 2016 tan horrible es el
precio a pagar para evitar que Argentina
se convierta en la nueva Venezuela.
La pregunta es, ¿deberíamos culpar a
macri de lo que está pasando o a la
herencia que le han dejado a los
Kirchner?
Dicho de otra forma, ¿veremos cómo caen
la inflación y Argentina se empieza a
recuperar el año que viene? ¿Vosotros
qué pensáis? Me podéis dejar vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios y
si os interesa este tema y queréis
seguirlo desde cerca suscribiros al
canal para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones. Como siempre,
si queréis profundizar más
encontraréis varios links en la
descripción. Si os ha gustado este video, dadle a
like  y nos vemos en el próximo.
¡Un abrazo y hasta pronto!